- Welcome to my shop.
We're back home
in Interlachen, Florida.
I like crazy stuff.
I like wild stuff.
You can see it
in the forges that I build.
We've got gas forges,
different variations.
Blower-type gas forges.
Atmospheric.
I put a lot of effort
in building these forges,
trying to make 'em look
like different animals.
We got some more big
weldin' forges right here.
Forged a lot of axes
in this one.
Got some more of my
critter forges sittin' here.
When we start buildin' em,
they take a life of theirself.
It's all built
out of scrap metal,
and you just gotta envision
what you're looking at,
and the piece just literally
falls together.
- Well, we're here
in Kingsley, Michigan.
I want to show you my shop.
Here, this is my forge.
I got LP gas.
I got a 110-CFM blower
off of a copying machine.
And here's a 25-ton
C-frame hydraulic press.
I use it primarily for welding.
Here's my 110-pound
pneumatic hammer.
Got a 5-horse motor.
Self-contained.
I have a surface grinder,
and I use this for making
my folding knives
and just about anything else
where you want
a nice, flat surface.
It's priceless.
- Got my anvil stations here.
Got three really nice
antique anvils that I use.
I searched for years
for most of 'em
to find the ones I wanted.
This right here
is a Sisco Superior.
It's a Swedish anvil.
They're all cast steel.
Any of the Swedish anvils
are really sought after.
They're probably some of
the best anvils ever made.
This is a 20-pound baby Fisher.
It's more or less like
a salesman sample.
They carry these around
instead of
carrying the big anvils around.
When you look at my shop,
it's all...
kind of unique to what I like.
There's nothing fancy about it.
[music fades out]
- And here we got
my belt grinder.
I made this little tree here
to hold my attachments
for the grinder.
Got a 2-horse motor.
Three-phase.
It has speed control on it.
And I have
this 14-inch band saw
that is a six-speed.
Saws steel, and it saws wood.
Really I think my handiest tool
around here,
so it really has served me.
I've had this
about maybe 30 years now.
Still runs great.
This is my shop.
I hope you'd enjoy it.
Thanks for checking it out.